the life on earth is an amazing story
the planet forms around 4.5 6 7 billion
years ago the first rocks that appear to
have any chemical evidence of life show
up around 3.8 billion years ago then by
3.5 billion years ago we actually see
evidence of these bacterial mounds let
me wait a long time before we see any
life-forms that are large the first
large large life-forms show up about 600
million years ago and there are seafloor
organisms that are now extinct it looked
like place mats believe it or not after
that there's somewhere around 500
million years as an explosion of marine
life
lots of diversification the first
organisms there related to the different
groups of marine animals you find today
it's not till about 400 million years
ago that the first life emerges onto
land the first little arachnid
spider-like organisms early plants or
only a maybe a centimeter tall wait
another hundred million years your first
forest your first large bodied
terrestrial animals things like giant
millipedes and the first land living
vertebrates evolving from fish sometime
after that animals four-legged animals
finally learn how to eat plants it took
a while for the first terrestrial
herbivores to appear that happens
somewhere around 300 million years ago
and that is a major extinction that
happens at two hundred and fifty million
years ago don't really know the cause
but something to do with the
perturbation the Earth's carbon cycle
where we lose something like ninety
percent of the species of the planet
when they disappear it's an ear shape
for life on Earth but out of that grows
the age of the dinosaurs and for 150
million years we have a world that's
warm a world that is so warm there are
no polar ice caps and in that world a
great diversity of animals that start to
look familiar to you cohabit with the
dinosaurs we get the first birds we get
the first mammals we still have these
large dinosaurs and then it's 66 million
years ago an asteroid the size of Denver
traveling 20 times the speed of a bullet
crashes into the Yucatan Peninsula and
causes a massive extinction of all
animals that are larger than dogs on the
planet the recovery from that is the
footing for our modern world that's what
we see the evolution of the Bur
birds the mammals we know marine mammals
and then the temperature starts to cool
down driving forests away building the
ice caps that we know creating
grasslands and about eight million years
ago the first humans ancestors appear in
the savannahs of Africa and evolved
through time and eventually colonized
the world arriving here in North America
about 13,000 years ago and create
agriculture and domestication of animals
about 10,000 years ago and cities and
eventually we learned to dig and use
fossil fuels a couple hundred years ago
and create the great civilizations we
live in now